rats where this brat is in Kansas City
hi Brett how are you I'm good day thank
you for taking my call it's a pleasure
absolutely how can I help sir well my
car is I've held on to it for 12 years
it's on its last leg so I think I'm
going to have to get a new one but
that's not really my question that's got
me thinking I kind of feel sometimes
like I'm addicted to saving and and
people tell me all the time that I take
it overboard I need to enjoy my money
and sometimes I agree with that and
think that might not be such a bad idea
but then the next day I wake up and
think oh my gosh I'm not going to get
where I need to be unless I I constantly
save so I kind of wanted to just get
your input and give me some direction
okay well let me let me kind of give you
before we get into your numbers in the
situation there let me kind of give you
a way to know if you're out of balance
on something okay okay and the way I
look at it is I use ratios okay if for
instance it sounds like you need a new
car
and you have saved five million dollars
and you're freaking out over spending
fifteen thousand bucks to go get you a
good used car the duke you're out of
line you know come on right right that's
a very small percentage of your world
but if you're sitting there you know and
you got fifty thousand dollars to your
whole name and your broke friends are
suggesting you're going to go buy twenty
five thousand on our car right now then
your broke friends are stupid because
see that ratio is different you follow
me right and so you know in you should
always be enjoying and spending some
percentage of your money you should
always be saving some percentage of your
money and you should always be giving
some percentage of your money and if you
can't do that then that's where we know
we're messed up so how much is in your
nest egg my net worth is about a hundred
and forty three thousand dollars okay
what do you make a money
I grow 60 I look 5200 in my 401k a year
yeah
my total expenses a month are about two
thousand that's including I just got a
mortgage last year I all of my 401k and
all of my expenses are paid I have about
eleven hundred dollars a month that I
took in a band guard index mutual fund
mm-hmm
so I I feel like I do a pretty decent
job of saving I don't
are you giving material yes okay and I
don't I don't need a lot of fancy things
and I'm not embarrassed by my car right
what what are you what are you spend on
that's just fun what do you call fun
that costs money um well I like to sing
karaoke a lot so I'll got on the
weekends back to the bar all right and
so uh I mean that's an indulgence right
I mean and so your car is worth what do
you think today you may maybe fourteen
and the repair bills thirteen hundred
you know or probably times are probably
time to move up in gone so if I said go
buy a seven thousand dollar car with
that freak you out yes all right then
that then you're right you're a little
bit tight on that part of it because
you've got the money in that Vanguard
account it how much is in that Vanguard
account 6061 yeah Alison and so $7,000
is not going to damage your world I'm
not suggesting buy a $50,000 car okay
but if you bought a $7,000 car your
world's not going to change your future
is not going to change or be in jeopardy
and you know to the extent you can't and
you're sitting there driving a piece of
crap that's out it that's done I mean
it's done you don't spend thirteen
hundred bucks on a fourteen hour car
that but just be good money after bad
and so it's time for you to move up a
little bit in car and get you something
a little bit nicer by the way the
difference in the seven thousand dollar
car or fourteen hundred other cars not a
little bit it's light your
different but but you know it's time for
you do that yeah you're right you are
probably a little tight on that but are
you completely like over-the-top got
some kind of savings illness or
something
no you're just you just have a tendency
and natural tendency toward saving but
make sure you're making reasonable
spending decisions reasonable giving
decisions along with what is borderline
unreasonable saving yeah doing that
you'll be okay you're fine okay good I'm
trying to get to that million dollar
mark I want to be able to call into your
show yeah you're on your way Minh you're
going to make it you're doing good
you're doing really good congratulations
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]